on pense qu'ils auraient d'abord des
économies importantes à faire
deuxièmement on voudrait aussi faire
faire des économies de temps et d'argent
aux contribuables
on va vérifier tout cela avec jean
pierre vidal qui est professeur
titulaire au département de sciences
comptables à hec montréal monsieur vidal
dont soir vous pensez quoi de cette
proposition de cette demande aujourd'hui
de françois legault
bah c'est une demande qui rejoint
sûrement beaucoup d'électeurs au québec
et au canada en général c'est assez
logique et rationnel de faire une seule
déclaration d'impôt d'ailleurs le reste
du canada à une seule déclaration
d'impôt qui est généralement une
déclaration fédérale
et ça c'est vrai pour toutes les
provinces et des territoires sauf dans
le domaine l'impôt corporatifs ou
l'alberta et l'exception avec le québec
c'est certain qu'une déclaration unique
permet d'économiser des coûts mais je
pense que cette demande est bien
davantage que juste de économiser des
coûts
c'est une affirmation politique et c'est
une affirmation politique très forte
oui mais sur le plan des coûts quand
françois legault dit par exemple qu'on
va économiser 500 millions de da de
dollars par année
si le québec gère seul ses déclarations
de revenus de ces contribuables est ce
que c'est exact monsieur legault
sûrement beaucoup d'experts qui lui
donne des chiffres
moi j'ai entendu des chiffres aussi de
500 millions je les ai entendus dans le
passé vous savez quand les gouvernements
font des estimations ils estiment
parfois des choses sous un oeil qui
ils n'ont pas tous les détails j'ai vu
par par exemple j'ai vu des estimations
qui était de 300 millions et la
différence c'est toujours l'évaluation
des dédoublements
quels sont les dédoublements qui vont
vraiment être éliminé c'est une question
à laquelle c'est difficile de répondre
actuellement parce que les employés
fédéraux ont pas encore été mis à pied
on ne sait pas combien vont être
engagées par le gouvernement provincial
on ne sait pas combien n'ont plus de
gens travaillent à des tâches qui sont
exactement les mêmes qu'au fédéral parce
que vous savez où gouvernement
provincial ont fait beaucoup de choses
d'une façon différente du gouvernement
fédéral en particulier pour tous les
crédits d'impôts alors on va économiser
de l'argent c'est sûr mais est-ce qu'on
va économiser 500 millions est ce qu'on
veut économiser 400 est-ce que c'est
très difficile de dire un chiffre précis
bon c'est important de mettre dans le
contexte aussi de budget de 110
milliards à québec donc 500 millions
potentiel d'économies pour le
gouvernement pour les citoyens est-ce
qu'ils auraient une économie les
citoyens s'en rendront par contre les
citoyens vont se rendre compte qu'ils
ont pas de déclaration à faire qu'on
parle de gagner peut-être c'est déjà ça
de l'art et de paperasses et de casavant
ces raisons et particulièrement les gens
qui ont déjà connu les déclarations
papier vont certainement se reconnaître
la dame et les déclarations papier il ya
plus personne qui en fait un peu de nos
jours les gens rentrent d'abord beaucoup
beaucoup de gens le font faire part des
services spécialisés et beaucoup de gens
remplissent des cases à partir de leurs
feuilles étaient quatre à partir leurs
feuilles étaient cinq dans un logiciel
et tout se fait automatiquement
alors est ce que les gens vont
actuellement tout le monde à qui on pose
la question vont tous est favorable
parce que c'est une simplification qui
semble logique
est-ce qu'ils vont vraiment s'en rendre
compte après avoir pu donner les
chiffres dans le logiciel
peut-être peut-être points est-ce qu'on
aurait un gain d'impôt est ce que leur
revenu imposable changerait si avec une
sous déclaration
ça c'est une question très délicate
parce que le québec depuis toujours
jalousement défendu son droit à la
distinction en matière fiscale pour
faire des programmes de promotion
économique donc favoriser certaines
industries favoriser certains groupes
sociaux et je pense est probable qu'ils
reportent vraiment de changements en
terme de deux objectifs fiscaux du
québec
donc ce serait surprenant que si on
élimine les deux formulaires
ça veut dire pour autant qu'on va avoir
une uniformisation du calcul du revenu
ou de quelques du revenu imposable ou
même du calcul de l'impôt absolument
est ce que il y aurait un impact sur les
vérifications fiscales vérification
fiscale internationale
la vérification fiscale internationale
est un point très délicat parce que
actuellement le gouvernement fédéral au
le lien avec les autres pays
est ce lié avec les autres régions du
monde avec les organisations
internationales
le québec pourrait difficilement l'avoir
actuellement
est-ce que éventuellement on pourrait
aménager des accords avec le fédéral est
ce que tout ça c'est un peu nébuleux
présentement mais chose certaine
actuellement ça poserait des problèmes
importants c'est du jour au lendemain on
disait le gouvernement fédéral ne
s'occupent plus d'aucune vérification
des multinationales ni d'aucune
vérification internationale parce que
présentement d'une part l' expertise le
les fonctionnaires provinciaux ont une
grande expertise mais le gouvernement
fédéral a une expertise en
internationale
et là il faudrait réfléchir comment
est-ce qu'on va transférer cette
expertise leur graal embauches des
fonctionnaires
les fonctionnaires fédéraux mais là se
pose la question des économies d'échelle
parce que présentement les
fonctionnaires fédéraux et prend un
exemple le grand patron de la
vérification internationale à ottawa
démissionnera pas demain matin pour
devenir fonctionnaire au québec
donc le québec va voir on va pouvoir
engager des bonnes personnes qui sont
des experts
le gouvernement du québec a déjà ses
propres experts en fiscalité
internationale
mais c'est sûr qu'ils pourraient pas
prendre la charge de vérifier toutes les
multinationales demain matin donc
autrement dit ce serait un transfert qui
prendrait un certain temps et une
certaine complexité
oui en particulier à cause des échanges
d'information actuellement on est dans
une nouvelle ère en fiscalité
internationale où il ya des
communications extrêmement importante
avec les autres pays
lagence probablement est en train
d'assimiler tous les changements récents
et là ce serait un fardeau
supplémentaire qui s'ajoutera aux
revenus à revenu québec jean pierre
vidal merci beaucoup pour ses
explications ce soir d'un grand plaisir
merci beaucoup